that's it you got to the gala I think
that's the title you're getting to the
gala
let's go jets from when we first started
he's gotten like so much more flexible
like in every part like his back has
kept everything
in Latin language like zero zero let's
say it doesn't matter to breakfast gosh
8:07 a.m. got caught up with the kids so
rushing 8 a.m. breakfast hate being late
worst feeling but little investor
breakfast right now and networking with
an angel series a investor
are you just getting in oh yeah a little
a little daily blog all good
what's up everybody I just had an
amazing meeting with Gary Vee he just
blows me away every single time I meet
with him he's so inspirational I
remember when he started vaynermedia
five years ago it's just like growing
into this massive company there's this
very rare moment this is one of the
painters lost no I thought this would
come up I didn't think it would come so
much came up immediately immediately
yeah I really don't want I'm Eric I
rejoined vaynermedia four months ago now
I was here in the early days 2011 and
what I'm working on with Gary is I'm
working on opening up a London office so
we're going to open an office in London
for vaynermedia luckily my floors
and work with Yahtzee
so I bought bombing on a real man - yes
- Daley's is always on there which lit
man I live in Arizona nice fun this year
YouTube relationship I want you to miss
in the fan moment alright good morning
what is it the Iraq 11:04 got in for
substantial meetings already obviously
my life's breaking down into running
Dehner
and and doing a VC investing behavior so
we went to and - on those meetings so
it's good allocation of two and a half
hours now we're headed to the part that
I think this blog is going to allow me
to show a little bit more up which is I
think people are always asking me how do
i balance my family life so right now
we're going to Xander's Hanukkah party
at his preschool
it's been fun I I really didn't for a
long time break my day up with family
but uh my my my kids are growing up and
they're having these events and I'm
absolutely hacking an arbitrage I'm
making sure that I'm spending time on
the important things so excited that a
when I'm in town if they've got stuff
going on at school or any of their
activities I'm desperately trying to
talk about the time to be there so
are you air going to Mickey cloud
he runs the Chattanooga's office they'll
make you how are you good brother how
was your weekend
that was huge god I wanted that one we
always want to be consultants we always
want to get paid for our advice like
we're not in the masonry business but at
the other day it's their call we just
never want them to feel like we're not
we're always gonna - about the best
advice you know what I can jump out here
my friend yeah just really quick cuz
it's right up here in the corner I'll
just go come on
thank you alright sup [ __ ] whew is
right look bad there for a while hey
poor mom my mom and dad are four no they
have to do they mom was probably
secretly losing the lose cuz secretly
rooting to lose cuz she didn't wanna go
next up I mean she's like I'm like mom
we're going to Dallas she's like uh how
to catch up with my sis
hey don't kept cool man Brian ready
Debra out of the rest of meeting them
12:14 you rock no moments to spare time
to call Brando there's a second email
for $6.99 boys not 100% sweeter it's so
much I'm so pumped you guys are there
there's a lot we got a lot we gotta
figure out I love you look I love you
more
do you live around the country so I
wasn't linking back you get back
oh yeah yeah I haven't back though
weights up told you oh yeah
like literally the ebb and flow of the
news I didn't call you what's going with
the game like as it was like a problem I
didn't respect you the Giants were
scoring you guys lost the most I don't
want to I don't want about live good
news and bad news
keep miss Venge so there are no
first-class seats - from Miami to LA
that's bad news first class okay um
dinner tomorrow I just take you back I'm
trying seven different okay I've got two
days recording the engine is no I'll get
it out into this one's nine six one nine
to 4:30 what we could make it 9:00 to
6:30 couldn't give me a 1 - like I'll be
in the studio - [ __ ] 4:00 in the
morning I'll ask ya if they can't move I
guess I owe them that you can get there
I'll take a call okay you're here
uh no just not wearing a hat but I did
cut my hair
yeah 33 in sign consent forms no I am
your consent form
hello come I don't can we do this in
your office yeah Susan your office I
mean and I want to get your guys kind of
read on sixty kind of what we were
trying to do you know what you want to
do one more time or whatever good pull
something yeah 170 right yeah let's do
it
there you go everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and make sure you watch
tomorrow's dailyvee I'm excited about
this dear Rach I think we're up to
something 120 videos for client cool
all right I don't know it's 120 Oh guys
thank you so much for the thing that
matters the most which is your attention
great
what's up vaynermedia it is your CEO
Gary Vaynerchuk Jack yes I want you to
say it to daily meal at 3 o'clock the
new site goes live you say will go live
at 3 o'clock
what is that no way they just come in
well yeah
is this everything it's gonna be
anything about I mean I know it's gonna
be hard covered it yeah that's a nice
empty boat but this is my daily be so
awesome in fact you get that because
then huh
don't good Zach feel good it's a lot of
emotions right now all right
it's cool it's cool too many things
going on right now but it's like did the
feedback from the email list help a lot
yeah come on good stuff yeah major major
so nothing major a lot of the stuff was
stuff that Caroline and I kind of knew
already but some of them were pretty
helpful and like offered suggestions
bosses Amazon the show a 274 yes
bringing the sudden what gb1 image
Amazon search 474 hey how are ya good
live streaming with Leo legends in the
game can make her I'm gonna periscope
for a second why don't you tell
everybody what I'm doing and then just
step out and tell them what the link is
you know I mean it
we gotta get stung we gotta get stung
one here say hello yes hey Leo what's up
man oh dude I'm I'm fangirling so hard I
seriously I've been watching the TWiT
Network since I'm evil since before you
guys were doing to it live for like a
million years cheers all right Greg you
like
maybe that shimmer wax in your ears okay
okay
thank you I'm super-pumped that's how
you know it would be well anyway thank
you so much have a great holiday
everybody take care of
yeah how you doing oh I've gone good
stuff
time to leave by 5:30 how do you want to
have a Orianna 15-minute meeting good
news is the answers I will see her for
three minutes they'll be oversized and
one second yeah and then why oh I just
told him it could be a 20 Thanks
losses I'm willing to there I just don't
know what's going on there hi I'm
Jessica will I'm an account manager and
the experience was good it's always a
little nerve-wracking you know going to
meet Gary you haven't met him before but
he's super personable and monetary into
getting to know who you are how you feel
about the company and how I can help
so it was super awful hey I'm Pam
Barrett and the director of recruiting
here at vaynermedia if I were to say any
one thing about that meeting is that
what you see is what you get with Gary
seems like a great guy to you he really
is he's a great guy to us cool Dave yeah
let's start the conversations of what's
on your mind when you're in my mind this
is chess [ __ ] I'm gonna take a
piss there's gonna be dinner delight I
may not eat again okay it's gonna be a
good nice sit-down dinner boys yeah I'll
do the right thing sir thank you
Oh teddy yep
oh hey nice feeling I was gonna erupt my
device in a good bit I'm an investment
me too I mean it was big come kill
seized a giant fan so ourselves against
mouth sings on four Super Bowls we
haven't been to any he'll be okay this
point as you can tell we've gotten a
shitload of stuff in on the day very
typical day in fact what I wanted to
kind of like jump in while I had two
minutes here to talk about was how
pissed I am at so many of you that have
been following me for a long time to
have my whoa after watching oh one wait
a minute that's a lot oh that's what it
takes
oh that's how so oh it's great to see it
for real oh I didn't realize it was so
much I was really pissed because I'm
like yeah what do you think as a matter
of fact what was so ironic about the day
we did the first episode was
unfortunately a business associates good
friend of mine and a business associate
his mother passed away so as he saw an
episode of one I had to go do a Shiva
call which wiped out my entire evening
of 7:00 p.m. to midnight meetings five
different meetings and when I thought
was so ironic was reading and first of
all thank you so much for the feedback
because the comments are my oxygen
reading all those comments everybody
talking about like oh that's what he did
oh crap there is real hustle it was
funny because that contradicts when I
walked into because when I got home
10:30 11:00 Lizzy literally looked at me
as I walked in and said why are you home
so early
like what are you doing here and I was
already reading the comments uh you know
on the next day and I was just like
showing Lizzy and she was like like it
was such a funny moment with my wife I'm
excited about it I'm enjoying the this
process and I want you to know how much
it means to me that you're watching but
most of all I am excited because I hope
I guess I didn't realize this when we
did it I guess this is going to help put
a cherry on top of the sundae of like
the work is to work there's no talking
about it there's no going on the
askgaryvee show and pontificating about
it but then not actually living I mean
some people
things like oh I heard entrepreneurs
don't work that much like I was I was
absolutely intrigued by the feedback and
I'm excited for you guys to continue on
this journey because get ready to be
very exhausted oh we're too is right
yeah I'm gonna see you as a wife
okay but oh but not for everybody oh
wait two minutes can all hands off hard
okay are you listening me yes um if you
can hold your presenter okay I just want
to give you 100%
I don't understand let's go Brandon I
don't give a [ __ ] let's go Dylan it's
like the pipes go
snap yeah my foot gbm's oh yo hold hands
come in now okay let's go let's go
what's the matter with you guys I knew
15 was gonna be [ __ ] [ __ ] on this
until God let's go [ __ ] 501 our
service with a [ __ ] like what what what
about 5 p.m. 3 now understand resin
Oh hands let's go all hands not some
hands
let's go along all hands not some here
so Jane I see you
a lot of employers
good afternoon as I continue to kind of
pay attention to the pulse of the
company and people handling this day of
the year better than we ever had before
which seeks the maturity and confidence
and things of that nature so I think it
would be appropriate because I'd like
loud sounds right now for everybody to
clap up each other for your I spend
enormous amounts of time trying to be
efficient trying to figure out
efficiencies for this company and
something has become pretty inefficient
at scale given the scale that we're at
which is the time cycle and cadence that
we deploy promotions and raises and so
we do that on a month-to-month basis we
really do it on a day to day basis and
there's a lot of work that goes into it
and so to find efficiencies we are going
to go to a more structured more
infrequent
you know pay bumps and promotion period
mini will give the details four times a
year things of that nature
what the reason I kind of wanted to make
sure everybody heard it from the horse's
mouth is nobody that's going to get
caught up in the new cycle much like we
did with V map with the CMS will be
negatively affected if anything some
people may get accelerations depending
on the timing but in 2016 we're going to
go and many will talk about it real
quick and then we'll send an email with
all the details but we're going to go
into a different cadence of not month to
month with promotions and raises but
more infrequent a couple times a year to
make our team more fish and make sure
we're crossing T's and eyes but I really
thought since [ __ ] it's the thing that
you guys care about tremendously because
it's your life I want to make sure that
you guys heard that the only thing we're
doing with this is to find a cadence not
that oh crap I'm not going to get a
promotion or raise two months earlier
things that make sure there's we've
spent almost once we decided all of our
time has been spent on nobody left
behind that could be affected because
they were supposed to get you know a
promotion or raise in February but we
started in January and somehow they got
affected
there's no they get burned in April we
will go through that systematically but
I
you hear that from me so you understood
where it was coming from thank you guys
have a great day thank you amazing I
want to buy his shoes because listen
first off just important is a casual
asking question Matt I'm gonna change
into my tux here oh I also don't want to
act tough little that's why we have
d-roc I don't have to follow you around
the city anyone talks talks are you guys
dinner oh thank you thank you
let's do it
go ahead
yes
someone big fan of what we just saw with
the all hands-on meeting I think it's
great to get everybody together and
aligned in one shot I think there's a
lot of efficiency in it and for the
minor inconvenience of wrangling
everybody up as you probably saw
depending how do you rock once to edit
you get to kind of drop a bomb and
everybody gets to see it right it's just
like one big moment and I find in big
organizations especially fast smart lean
organizations that are that are the role
the way we do that that there's a lot of
the players at that meaning that know
how to keep up with that kind of speed
and cadence and so I'm proud of that
I think we've breeded that culture and
more partly have watched my company be
able to execute at that kind of level
and so I love the all hands-on allows me
to interact even at that level with the
employees and I like doing them
so I'm pretty convinced they're not
gonna let you in this private club
there's some rings that the rocks that
could be allowed in so he's going well
so far so long now see us promotion
yes damn you believe what suppose and so
far there yeah at all dogs it's all
great learning a bun good so far so good
so far so good in the best part and I
could say this is all this [ __ ] that I
can bring with me from vaynermedia
everyone is like we worked on Instagram
strategy today neither the rug here are
some seeds of knowledge so I would set
up for success thank to you and then we
just met up randomly LinkedIn and I got
to bump into you guys awesome
in the Jets awesome and the just one I
mean that's not really like let's go
who's all that story about this runnin
is you in a suit yeah I know
whoa rare oh sorry yeah be rocking it
82nd and 5th
what a hook is everyone
now we're at the gala as I'm decked out
and the best part is the 3:45 a.m.
wake-up call
because I have a 5:40 flight go there
yeah maybe I'll push it to a for a a
week the Internet's fault not your fault
but like by the top right like some
people right now will see the new
website but I'm gonna try to pull up my
phone right now and see if I get it
okay Norris I'm sure by tomorrow we'll
all right cool thanks brother
love you too alright let's see if I have
it on my phone that was AK new sights
not up just it's been pushed but not
showing up everywhere in the world
I don't even ask for my name anymore cuz
I was typing vaynermedia I actually
misspelled it here I get this that's
what happens
have the old one damn it the new one to
like stick it no I'm going I'm going I'm
going to the charity warga gala and then
tomorrow every 4 a.m. wake up call
flying to Miami keep it keep in a real
hurry yo rainin Harvey I'm snapping for
charity water I just got here from where
floor in there I think this is where it
is
you got an MSD on that calls you so
that's it we got to the gala I think
that's the title you're not getting to
the gala
charity water gala an incredible
organization Scott Harrison I'm such a
good job I think most of you know what
charity water is but if you don't I do
rock link it up right here
great day got a lot in the thoraseal is
e inside spending some time with her
supporting a tremendous cause 4 a.m.
wake up call you'll be here at 11:00
11:30 hanging jamming seeing some
friends doing good stuff
we enjoy to have you guys around this is
really fun you're trying to do up see
you soon maybe I'll try to get some
footage of there
thank you
the amazing place
hello this way thank you it's getting
louder
so it means I'm close to you guys
combined tickets for buying tables for
contributing to this event we've already
helped a lot of people you're going to
hear more about that later and the goal
but we're so so excited you guys could
be anywhere tonight and you chose to
spend your time with us